in deutschland geht die angst um die
grünen machen häuser wahlkampf und auch
bei ihm kann es jeden moment an der tür
klingeln aber bevor ich die beiden
grünen haustür wahlkämpfer treppe will
ich erst mal wissen was die menschen von
der aktion halten die grünen machen
gerade häuser wahlkampf und fiel von tür
zu tür für das gut nein nein würden sie
keinen grünen rheinland nein ich lasse
die so kein rein den ich nicht kenne zum
beispiel katrin göring eckardt kennen
wir ich mir ganz egal wer das ist aber
ich will keine an der tür haben ich
informiere mich anderweitig kleine
warnung die grünen sind in der stadt da
sag ich mal grün ist leben und wo das
leben ist wenn ich auch ich sage immer
lieber ein haus im grünen als ein grünen
im haus dagegen sagen ich grün lässt
sich nicht verderben es sollte man
vergiftet das grün der ist das queue
leider tot sind die poet oder haben sie
irgendwie die hand genommen
ich bin zurück und wenn die anrufen
richtig auf
also für mich nicht super mal sehen wie
es mit den beiden kandidaten würden okay
leute ich würde sagen wir proben jetzt
erstmal den schlachtruf was ist grün und
klingelt an türen michael kellner
michael schon alle mit weimar klingelt
mich wenn der keller zweimal klingelt
dann wird die witze macht hier schon
immer noch ich ersten situation hier
wird jetzt geklingelt
das im grün-roten vorbeikommen von
landtagswahl macht er auch noch aus wer
auch immer auf gemacht hat als die
bürger sehen wer da kommt bleibt die
wohnungstür
[Musik]
erst haben wir acht mal geklingelt keine
art aufgemacht wie es die erste
zwischenbilanz
das auto fährt mal gucken wie sich leute
geht ja wir haben jetzt gerade nochmal
flyer in den briefkästen dass ich nur da
wo keine werbung drauf stand oder zimmer
weiter im nächsten haut kommt man
immerhin schon mal ins gespräch auch
interesse am thermomix wir sind vom
stern tv wehen haben auch alle häuser
gleich aus
dann kann es sein dass immer die fläche
auslaufen hieß es nach dem gespräch
werden wir jetzt die grünen nicht wert
oder auf gar keinen fall wählen
überlegen hatte sich gern als auf die
anderen lernen können die beiden noch
tun hat es wieder her natürlich auf
welcher etwa die man der herr nur einer
von beiden oder der jungen pärchen steht
zu ihren falten vielleicht ihn dann
kommt wieder lange übermittlungen im
haus nummer 4 macht eine wg einen
entscheidenden fehler
und letzten grün in die wohnung
[Musik]
kandidat antreten wer sehr lange lange
mehr
haben die beiden überzeugt wird ihr
sagen ja dass man gute argumente die
wählen wir künftig noch zu verschlafen
aber grenzwertig mit den positiven
nutzen den speicherbereich doch nicht
leute wir sind doch eh seit ewigkeiten
hier die wittener nicht machte die
grünen wählen wie viel zeit war ich die
noch verbringen
ich hoffe ich mal wir bekommen wir
machen jetzt mit leuten ins gespräch zu
kommen mit load verorten hier bekommt ja
das sehe ich anders kinder damit ich
hier auch noch was mitnehmen für den tag
und dann kann der bundesgeschäftsführer
den beiden doch noch helfen indem ein
fan foto macht und war mit ihr
ich habe langsam das gefühl ich muss den
beiden grünen mal unter die arme greifen
wenn wir nicht aufmachen erhöhen wir
ihnen die steuern führen die beiden
herren verfolgen mich schon den ganzen
abend können über die die polizei rufen
endlich erfolgreicher abend neigt sich
dem ende zu ich würde sagen zum abschied
kommen wir noch mal den schwarzen locken
aber jetzt ist was ist grün und klingelt
an türen hinterher werde diese wahl
verlieren martin scholl und an jeder
merkel
[Musik]
[Applaus]